today we're talking about how cd projekt
is showing support for ukraine and what
you can do to help as well
[Music]
cd projekt the parent company of witcher
and cyberpunk 2077 developer cd projekt
red has joined global efforts to levy
sanctions against russia for its
invasion of ukraine it has announced
that it will halt all digital and
physical sales of its games to russia
and belarus as well as all game sales on
its digital platform gog cd project also
recently pledged what equates to about
240 000 u.s dollars to a polish
humanitarian group in a statement cd
project group said quote in light of the
russian military invasions in our
neighboring country of ukraine until
further notice the cd projekt red group
has made the decision to halt all sales
of our games to russia and belarus cd
projekt also stated that it's aware that
it doesn't have the power to directly
influence matters on the global stage
but it does hope that by adding its
voice to a growing number of
entertainment brands that have blocked
russia and belarus from accessing their
content it can help inspire change in
those countries a growing number of
gaming entities have publicly moved to
distance themselves from russia and call
for an end to the invasion of ukraine
the deputy minister of ukraine has
called on sony and microsoft to also
join in on sanctions though neither has
yet done so bluebird team is also
suspending sales of its games in russia
and belarus as a sign of solidarity for
ukraine ea announced this week that
russia would be removed from its fifa 22
and nhl 22 games in the coming weeks
meanwhile various other gaming industry
studios have organized relief efforts
this war of mine developer 11-bit
studios is donating all proceeds from
sales of the anti-war game over the next
week to the ukrainian red cross stalker
2 developer gsc world which is based in
ukraine called on the gaming industry
and players to donate to a fund to help
aid the ukrainian armed forces if you'd
like to help the ongoing humanitarian
efforts we've organized a list of
organizations like the ukrainian red
cross and unicef that you can donate to
the link will be included in the video's
description but okay that was a very
important but also very heavy topic to
cover so let's switch gears a little bit
and talk about some lighter news
a new trailer for kirby in the forgotten
lands has been released today and it
doesn't reveal too much new info but
does go over the game's enemies the
beast pack and the multiple
transformations that kirby can use this
includes some extra versions about full
mode like stair's mouth and pipe mouth i
almost wish i was joking with those
names to help anyone who's still on the
fence about picking up the next kirby
game nintendo has also released a
sizeable demo on the switch's eshop
available right now and for free
kirby in the forgotten lance demo lets
users play through three levels which is
most of the game's first world meanwhile
over in destiny 2 land players are no
longer able to exploit the throne world
reputation gains in the latest patch
update bungie is tightening up a number
of smaller and more persistent issues in
the game which range from general
maintenance to ensuring that players
can't abuse and exploit the exploit in
question allows players to repeatedly
open specific chests in the expansion's
new patrol zone enabling them to quickly
max out their reputation with the local
vendor finch instead of organically
leveling up through bounties and
missions you can read about all the
fixes and more in the patch notes over
on gamespot.com
make sure to check the links in the
description if you have the means to
donate we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you